una aterrador antes y después imágenes
satelitales muestran el cambio radical
que ha sufrido la ciudad de bahamut tras
meses de incesantes bombardeos rusos en
2021 Back mood era una de las ciudades
más prósperas de Ucrania los habitantes
realizaban sus actividades diarias sin
el temor de perder la vida en el proceso
hoy más de un año después del inicio de
la guerra la ciudad está en ruinas las
fuerzas rusas con apoyo del grupo de
mercenarios Wagner han declarado haber
tomado control de bakmuth Aunque
expertos mencionan que ya no hay ningún
interés estratégico por la ciudad
en términos reales en no queda nada así
que el control de la zona no es militar
es político el problema ahora es que los
rusos se encontrarán en una zona en la
que puede que ni siquiera sean capaces
de permanecer a largo plazo porque la
infraestructura no existe la capacidad
de mantener la ciudad y continuar hacia
el oeste va a ser muy difícil
durante la Cumbre del g7 el presidente
ucraniano voló de inmersa lensky comparó
la destrucción en bakmuth con la que
hubo en Hiroshima después de la bomba
nuclear que le dio fin a la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
Pues aquí hay una foto de la tragedia de
Hiroshima y es todo lo que vemos ahora
y ya vamos creo que lo mismo ocurrirá en
Mac mood y en nuestras otras ciudades
desgraciadamente o hizo una tragedia
pero en el futuro habrá reconstrucción
ha sido una de las ciudades más
afectadas por la guerra al ser
considerada como una ubicación
estratégica por ambos bandos sin embargo
esto ha costado la destrucción de lo que
alguna vez fue el hogar de unas 70.000
personas